honey good afternoon we start with some
breaking news and rmt union members at
Network Rel have voted to accept a pay
offer now this means that thousands of
signal workers and maintenance staff
will not take part in any more strikes
in a long-running dispute overpay jobs
and working conditions well the offer
includes a pay rise of up to 14.4 for
the lowest paid and 9.2 percent for the
highest paid
workers will also get a total increase
in basic earnings of up to 15.2 percent
for the lowest pay grade and 10.3
percent for the highest
and the offer also includes a renewing
of the no compulsory redundancy
agreement until January
2025. well let's bring in Skies Leonard
this line image now who's in The
Newsroom for us so Melinda does this
then spell the end of the strike action
then the long ongoing strike action for
the Union
not quite it spells the end of the
strike action concerning people working
for the network rail like signalers like
maintenance staff however there is still
a dispute between the union and the 14
rail companies as well as between the
union aslev but the Train Drive is Union
and the rail companies and those strikes
are still going to go ahead on the 30th
of March and the 1st of April unless
there is a breakthrough in between now
and then however this has been a very
significant move by the union and that's
because those Network rail strikes were
the most disruptive of them all because
you really can't run a trained Network
without signalers or track maintenance
staff that's when we see all of those
timetables being canceled and it was a
decisive yes for this deal there was a
turnout of 90 percent of rmt members 76
of them voted in favor of this deal
you've said some of the things that are
on that were on the table in terms of
the offer that's all increases over two
years I think there was one crucial
difference that the union says was
significant between the offer that was
accepted and the previous offers and
that was that they say that Network
rails stopped insisting on that
compulsory maintenance modernizing
maintenance agenda on the one hand
Network rail said that that would have
made the whole system more efficient
maybe condense some of those hours the
engineers were working on the other hand
the union said that that would result in
thousands and thousands of jobs being
slash now the union says that that is
now off the table there also won't be
any compulsory redundancies until
January
2025 so it is a significant breakthrough
but of course that other dispute still
continues between the rail delivery
group and the union and in that sense
the transport secretary Mark Harper
reacted to today's news but he has
condemned the r t leadership for not
putting that separate deal to vote for
their membership I'm going to read you a
tweet that he posted a short time ago
and it he said
while this is good news unfortunately
rmt members who work for train operating
companies are not being given the same
chance to bring their dispute to an end
that's because the rmt has refused to
put the rail delivery groups a very
similar offer to a vote denying those
members the pay rise they deserve that's
why I'm once again urging the rmt to
call off their upcoming strikes across
train operating companies put the rail
delivery group offer to a vote and give
all of their members a say so a tale of
two halves really but undoubtedly a
significant breakthrough that will
perhaps inject some optimism in those
other disputes that there may be an end
to those strikes that we've been seeing
since last summer that have been costing
the commuters and businesses millions
and millions of pounds